- My name is Elvis Otieno
I live in Nairobi, that's in Kenya,
and I'm a country musician.
("Miller's Cave" by Elvis Otieno)
♫ Way down in
♫ The state of Georgia
One, two
("Down the Road" By Elvis Otieno)
♫ Down the road
♫ Mama wants to know
♫ If I'm washed in the blood
♫ Or just in the water
♫ Daddy wants to know
♫ If I make enough to take his daughter
Country music was my first love.
My parents, I think, looking back at it
were very unique in a way
because they loved country music.
They had all the records,
and I listened to all the beautiful music
that was there.
That, kind of like, shaped up the person
that I was to become later in my life.
We identify quite a lot with country music
because of the message that is in it.
Family, love, heartbreak.
("Me And Bobby Mcgee" by Elvis Otieno)
♫ From the coal mines of Kentucky
♫ To the California sun
I draw a lot of inspirations
from different singers,
and different songwriters.
Garth Brooks, Charley Pride, Alan Jackson,
Don Williams, George
Strait, Brooks and Dunn.
The list is endless.
The struggles they experienced
are really universal.
("One More Day" by Elvis Otieno)
♫ One more day
♫ One more time
Every time I've gone on
stage, I have to make sure
my audience are with me,
and they get my message.
And, usually what I want them to feel,
is the raw emotions of a song.
♫ Sad they start with me
♫ As I walk the streets of my memories
I'm just like a vessel, but through me,
they can feel the emotions
and it has to be real,
it has to come from your heart.
Thank you, thank you so much.
(chime)